Now imagine this it is 2005 the year
2005 and you are a software engineer and
you work basically at a e-commerce based
company and the company is rapidly
growing because it's 2005 because of the
com bubble etc right the company is
rapidly growing and you have a task you
are a software engineer and you have a
task to search through thousands of
products your company has around let's
say 5,000 products
And you have to write a database query
to create an API which searches given a
user input searches through your
database and returns some relevant
results. Right? And this is how you
write the query for that in a typical
relational database based setup. You say
select star from products where name is
like laptop. So these percentage symbols
are for matching any characters that
comes before and comes after that.
Either it can match name or it can match
description. If the keyword laptop is
either in name or in description, you
return those results. Right? This is how
you do a basic search and the customers
search for laptop. They get a few
results and life is very simple. Now
something happens since it is 2005 and
because of a lot of companies growth
your company also grew and it grew
rapidly. Suddenly you had millions of
products, right? The the very
straightforward I like and the person
symbol based search in your relational
database query that once returned
results in let's say 50 milliseconds.
Now it is taking 30 seconds and because
of that the your customers are
frustrated, your manager is frustrated
and everyone is asking you to optimize
it and you are clueless. They don't just
want to make it faster. They also have
more requirements. Requirements like can
we make the search smarter. For example,
when someone searches for laptop, you
want to show the most relevant results
faster. For example, let's say someone
searches laptop, instead of showing a
laptop bag, we want to show a MacBook
Pro first, right? So that kind of smart
searching, relevancebased searching. And
we also have a requirement that
customers are there in a hurry during
the sale time, right? So instead of
writing laptop, they are writing laptop
pretty frequently. And we also want to
take that into account even though they
make typos, customers make typos in
their user queries, we still want to
return relevant results for laptop
instead of laptop, right? We want to
make it faster. We want to make it
relevant. And we also want to be robust
enough that typos cannot break us. And
with all these requirements, this is the
story of why search engines like elastic
search came into place because of all
these requirements. And this is what we
are going to talk about to get the
intuition of it. Your posgress database
or whatever relational database that you
are using. Now that database is like a
librarian. You go to a librarian and you
ask a librarian the locations of
different different books or different
different categories. Right? So your
Postgress database is like a librarian
who knows exactly where every book is
located but it has one fatal flaw. So we
have our librarian here. If you ask the
location of a random book, then to find
that book, the librarian has to look
through every single book in every
single shelf in the whole library one by
one. That is its fatal flaw. So for
example, let's say you ask for a book
called machine learning. You go to the
library and you ask the librarian that I
am looking for books about machine
learning. Right? So the librarian starts
its search. It finds the first book. The
first book's name is Harry Potter and
the Philosopher Store. And it checks
that no, there is no machine learning in
this. Moving on. Then it finds that Game
of Thrones. Again, there is no machine
learning in that title. Moving on. Then
it finds a book which is called
Introduction to Machine Learning.
Finally has a match and it returns that.
Now that librarian will continue this
process of going through every book one
by one in the whole library. Depending
on the size of the library, it might
take a few minutes to a few hours in in
fact a few days if it's a huge library,
right? Let's say a library with 10
million or 1 billion books. That is one
thing. The time it takes to find all our
books. The second thing is the librarian
has no concept of relevance. And what do
we mean by relevance? In the sense that
if the librarian finds two books, in one
book, the the title name, the name of
the book is an introduction to machine
learning. And in another book, the word
the phrase machine learning is just
mentioned in the last page and the topic
is something else. But machine learning
is just mentioned there. And it returns
both of these books in any order it
wants, right? It can return the second
book which only has machine learning in
the last page which is not very relevant
and it can return that book first and
return the book named an introduction to
machine learning second. Even though if
you're asking for books about machine
learning, we want the first book is
titled as an introduction to machine
learning first and we might not even
want the second book because it is
pretty irrelevant in our use case.
Coming back to our databases, if you
think about the librarian, the example
that I talked about just before as our
database itself, then a query like this
where we use I like which is basically a
case insensitive
search and using percentage symbol. This
is exactly how the librarian looks for
books in a huge library. The database
has to scan every single row, examine
every single text field and perform
pattern matching character by character.
Now it is thorough. It is going to
return results results that are
matching. But it is painfully slow and
second thing the relevance thing. It
does not really know which books which
results are more important than others.
It returns them in a random order. We
might want some results. Some results
might be completely irrelevant and some
results might be very relevant but they
might be in the position of let's say
a,000 or 10,000 right the database has
no sense of what is the most relevant
result okay now coming back to our
history since we are talking about 2005
around the same time the information
explosion happened right there are so
many websites being built there are so
many servers databases and all these big
companies like Google was processing ing
billions of web pages it was indexing
crawling through them and Amazon as a
e-commerce company it was cataloging
millions of products and LinkedIn was
indexing millions of profiles and these
companies they cannot afford to wait 30
seconds for search results obviously
customers are going to leave the site 30
seconds is way too much in our current
standard even 2 seconds of delay is
considered considered a crazy amount of
delay especially when we are talking
about latency. Search results have to be
very fast. We are talking about
milliseconds here, right? So obviously
these big companies where they are
making millions and millions of dollars
every single second. They cannot afford
this kind of latency. This will affect
their conversion, their user base. So to
solve the problem of search the answer
came from decades of research. It was
not a new problem. There has been
countless research in in this field when
it comes to textbased search and
information retrieval since decades. And
computer scientists have been studying
how to get the results fast and keep
them relevant. and researchers,
scientists, computer scientists, they
have been investing a lot of time and a
lot of effort into it since the 1960s.
So the revolution in the idea came from
this particular uh key thought or key
idea that so instead of searching
through the documents in case of the
librarian instead of searching through
the books the title the content all the
books to find the relevant terms what if
we flipped the problem. What if we
inverse the problem? What if we look at
it in a different way? And that was the
birth of this key invention, the key
idea that changed textbased search
forever which is called inverted index.
Now this is a very simple concept even
though the implementation might have
more complicated stuff more mathematics
but for a highle understanding it is a
very simple concept that we are going to
talk about. Coming back to our earlier
example where we think about the
database as a librarian and we ask the
librarian we ask the librarian that we
want books related to machine learning
right and the librarian goes to every
book to search through the title to the
content to the description etc etc now
coming back to the same problem but this
time we look at it using this technique
called inverted index and the
revolutionary idea here is instead of
going through every book and checking
the existence of machine learning in
those books. What if while storing the
books in the shelf when the first time
the books arrive, we take all the words
in that book and we create an index of
those words in a way that for a
particular word we can find out that
what are all the books where this word
is used and also where exactly it is
used. For example, let's say we are
talking about machine. So machine is
used in this book called introduction to
machine learning in page 1, 15 and 23.
Same way another book called the machine
age here it is used on page five on page
89 and another book where coffee where
coffee machine manual it is used in page
one. Same way for learning introduction
to machine learning it has been used
three times 1 16 24 even though in a
practical scenario for a book called
introduction to machine learning the
words machine and learning will be most
likely used hundreds of times throughout
the books. For the sake of this example
we are just saying three pages but they
are most likely used in hundreds of
pages. Same way learning to cook it's
used in two places and deep learning
fundamentals it's used in three places.
Now we have this index which we call
inverted index. So instead of going
through the content and finding the
terms we have the terms and through the
terms we find the content. We just
inverted the search. That's why it's
called inverted index. And this
technique, this technique of inverted
index, this is the thing that powers
elastic search, a very famous tool. When
we are talking about full text search,
elastic search, elastic search also has
an history. It is not a completely new
invention. It makes use of this
technology which is called Apache
lucine. This is the key technology, the
key uh inverted index based technology.
which elastic search and a lot of other
tools. Elastic search is not the only
cool text search tool. In fact, these
days even relational databases like
posgress also have support for full text
search. So, elastic search is not the
only tool. We have also have a lot of
other tools full text search based tool
which most of them make use of this
underlying technology called Apache
Lucion which is primarily the inverted
index based text search technology. Now
that is one key concept. Now that we
have this inverted index, the librarian
can just refer to this. We say machine
learning, they can see that machine is
used in all these books and learning is
used in all these books. This is the
first thing the librarian and the
database. We are talking about both of
these things here just to make it more
intuitive. We are talking about
librarian but you can think about
database when we say librarian. Now the
librarian is faster but there is another
advantage and a huge advantage which is
relevance. So from these results we can
see that for the term machine it is used
in three places. Now as I said in a book
called introduction to machine learning
this term machine is most probably used
in hundreds of places but for this sake
of this example it's used in three
places and for the book the machine age
it is used in two places. Now the
elastic search technologies and tools
like elastic search they also have this
feature called relevance scoring we
don't have to understand how actually it
works understanding is good uh it is
definitely good to understand the
underlying architecture but again if you
just want to make use of the tool and
build a service then you can easily
refer to docs take the example and just
use it just have to know that if you
have a use case like this go with
elastic search or full text search from
posgress whatever your typical tech
stack is but you don't have to
completely understand all the
technologies what is happening behind
the scenes how the index works how the
scoring works etc it's it's pretty
complicated and unless you are writing
another library about elastic search or
creating alternative to elast elastic
search all that knowledge is not going
to help you a lot as long as you know
the best practices how to do certain
stuff that's pretty much enough now
coming back elastic search also has this
concept called relevant scoring which
means that it can check the term machine
is present in page one in the title of
the book that fact itself that the term
is present in title it gives a
significant boost to its relevant score
now this is the most relevant book for
our query since the term is present in
the title again after that we also see
that it is present present three times
throughout the book. Now that is again
another significant relevance booster.
It is present in the title and it is
present in more frequent places. Those
two things because of those two things
this result is came on top. Same way for
this book the machine age it is present
in the title. So that is one relevant
scoring but it is not as frequently
used. So that's why it is coming in the
second place. Same for the third thing.
It is present in the title but it is
very less frequently used. So that's why
we got it in the third place. And same
logic for this term also. So as you can
see using a tool like elastic search can
make the experience of search fast and
also give you this additional advantage
of relevance based results. We just
don't want any result that matches your
query. You want the most meaningful
result and elastic search tools like
elastic search give you that feature.
Now it has an algorithm called the BM25
algorithm. As I said there is a lot of
theory behind this. If you are
interested you can learn more about it.
But I would suggest just treat it as a
tool. Whenever you want to use it just
know that if I have a use case like this
I have to go with elastic search. then
just refer to the docs, implement the
feature and move on instead of spending
too much time understanding the theory.
But again, if you are curious then it's
great if you want to learn more then
elastic search docs is a very good place
to learn more about these things. So
this algorithm that it uses the BM25
algorithm it has different different
parameters to sort the results. So one
thing that we already talked about is
the term frequency. How often the term
machine appears in the document. How
often if we consider this book as a
document in elastic search all the a
single entity is called a document. It's
a JSON document kind of like MongoDB. So
the first category if we see it is term
frequency which checks that how often a
particular term is present in a
document. And the second category is
document frequency which checks that how
common is the term machine across all
documents. Right? This is in a single
document and this is across all
documents. Third one document length
which checks basically how long a
particular document is. If it is a short
document or a long book like document
then another thing is field boosting.
Now if you have worked with elastic
search before then field boosting
feature is something that we use a lot.
Field boosting basically means that this
term machine if it appears in the title
then that is more relevant as compared
to it appearing in the description and
it appearing in the description is more
relevant as compared to it appearing in
the content. Let's say for a particular
book we have a title then that is more
relevant than the description and that
is more relevant than the content. So if
a term appears in the title that is more
relevant than it appearing in the
description and that is more relevant
than it appear in the content. That is
what we call as field boosting. And
while making a search query we can say
we can define our own field boosting
criterias. We can say that if it appears
in the content then that should be more
relevant. So we can alter these things.
It's not fixed. It's upon us. The
elastic search DSL the the language that
we use. It's a JSON based query language
and it offers a lot of features a lot of
parameters to do different kinds of
search and using that we can extract
different different kinds of results. So
there are different use cases when we
are using elastic search. Apart from a
just basic text matching the first one
is of course the typo tolerance let's
say. So I will show you an example. So
we want to make Google search. Now this
is a very good example. We are not sure
what exactly the technology that Google
uses whether it is elastic search or
whether it is something proprietary that
Google has built on top of Apache Lucen
but it is a technology similar to
elastic search and you can build an
interface like this which is called a
type ahead interface uh using elastic
search right we have this in websites
like Amazon where you type something and
you get results I want to search what is
trending today so I start to write what
is So I already got a lot of results.
Now these results are scored in
different different parameters that
depends on Google. But I want to show
something else. I want to search what is
trending today. So instead of writing
trending, what if I write treading?
Trending today. So as you can see, we
wrote what is treading today. We
intentionally made a typo. But because
of this pull text search based
capabilities of tools like elastic
search they can derive from the context
that there is a typo and what is
trending today is the most likely
intended query of the user right and
this is a major advantage of using a
technology like elastic search full text
search based technology for these kinds
of experiences like typos and all right
so if you are building a search like
feature in your backend application then
you have two options you can go with
posgress now posgress as a modern
database it also offers a full text
search feature so you can go with
posgress or if your company already uses
elastic search now elastic search is a
tool is not just used for these kinds of
features like type ahead and full deck
search elastic search is a very famous
tool which is also used in the domain of
log management
So there is this very famous stack
called ELK stack. So if we look for Elk
stack, Elastic Search, Kibana and Lock
stacks. All these three technologies
combined a very famous stack for
managing logs etc. Right? Since elastic
search is very fast in searching things,
searching through logs and deriving
statistics and visualizing data etc etc.
There is a very famous use case of
elastic search. So if your company
already has elastic search as a part of
elk stack for log management then going
with elastic search for your full text
search based requirements also makes a
lot of sense instead of going with
posgress. Let's go through an example of
the difference between a traditional
database search and an elastic search
based search. I have a project here. It
is a nextjs based project. There is no
reason for creating it in nextJS just
that LLMs are very good at generating
these prototype based applications using
nextJS. That's why I went ahead with it
instead of writing my own in any other
language. In this project basically we
have a UI like this where we are
comparing we are executing query and
running that query in a traditional
posgress based database and also a
elastic search instance. To keep it
fair, I have created a project in neon
serverless cloud-based posgress instance
and a project in elastic cloud right and
both the instances are situated in the
region of US- west. So latency because
of distance should not be a big factor
in our test which or kind of benchmark
that we are going to do just now. But
before that I just want to explain what
I have done in this project for the
purpose of the demo. I created a table
called reviews in a posgress database in
the neon posgress database where the
table has three fields one ID one review
is a text field and one sentiment is
positive or negative that is the
database table then going to this script
which populates our database and our
elastic search index I have this very
big CSV file it is around 50,000 entries
of review and sentiment. I have
collected it from somewhere. I'm not
sure. So, it has two fields. It has a
review and it has a sentiment that
whether it is a positive review or
negative review, right? And it has
50,000 entries. And we want to insert it
first into our database and our elastic
search index. So, what am I doing? What
I'm doing here in the populate script is
it's a NodeJS script and I'm taking the
database URL from environment and
elastic search address and the elastic
search API key right if any of them are
not present I'm throwing an error then
we initialize the clients for the
database we start in neon client and for
the elastic search we start in elastic
search client is where we are building
the clients
Then we read the data from CSV. We are
just doing a read file sync and we are
reading the data and storing it in this
variable. Then first we populate the
Postgress instance. This is our script
to run which basically says that if this
table is not already existing then
create a table. But since I have already
run this migration once the table
already exists this part does not really
run. Then we are just resetting the ID
field so that we start fresh. Then we
are doing some kind of filteration so
that we have both the review and the
sentiment field. If it does not have it,
we're just filtering it out. Right? Then
we have valid records then we start
inserting them in batches. Since
inserting them all at once has a
limitation in the neon instance. We are
inserting them in batches. So we are
creating a batches of thousand and we're
looping through those batches and we are
just doing a normal insert statement
insert into reviews review and sentiment
and just in the values we are just
inserting the review and the
corresponding sentiment and we are
executing the query here. That's the
database part. Then we are populating
the elastic search if the index exists
or not. We are checking first whether
this elastic search index which is
called reviews exist or not. If it
already exists, we are deleting it since
we want to start fresh. If if it does
not exist, then here we are creating an
index. And in the inside that index,
here is how we map the fields. We're
saying that we have two fields. Review,
which is of type text, and sentiment,
which is of type keyword. Text basically
means that we don't want to do any kind
of discrimination around the different
words in the text. But keyword means
that we want to exactly match that
particular word. Now again we are
checking the val records by the present
of both the fields. Then we are doing a
bulk insert of all the 50,000 records in
the elastic search. So I have gone ahead
and run this script. You can see here
50,000 documents inserted to elastic
search etc. And if we check in our cloud
instance, you can see that in our
elastic search cloud instance, we have
50,000 documents here all populated.
Same for our neon uh database. So if we
come here in the SQL editor, if we run
this query, select count star from
reviews, then we get this value that
50,000, which means that we have 50,000
rows in our reviews table. So both the
database and the elastic search have
been populated successfully. Then what
am I doing here? This is the key part,
not the UI. UI is pretty generic. The
route. This is basically the API
endpoint which we call once the user
types something and hits enter runs the
query. This is the API we call. So what
exactly were we doing here? We are
taking the search term from the JSON and
if there is something wrong with it, we
just threw a bad request error and we
are starting a stream because the result
timing of the database and the elastic
search can be different and we don't
want to delay the result of one because
of the other. That's why as the results
are available to us, we are just
streaming it to our front end so that we
can immediately see which one is faster
and how much time it is taking. Right?
For that we are just starting a new
stream here. And this is our posgress
search. And what are we doing? We are
just starting a timer to track how much
time it took to run the query. And this
is the query that we are running. Select
these three fields from reviews table
where review is like this search term as
I have already shown in the just a while
back. This is how we typically do a
search in a relational database. We use
I like because we want to do a case
insensitive search to cover more uh
breadth and we put the percentage sign
before and after the term to say that we
it does not matter what character comes
before it and after it as long as the
term is present itself we want to take
that result. Then we have this query and
we are just running it and taking all
the information that comes with it and
we are just sending the result. End
result is the function which actually
streams the data to our front end as the
data is available. Right? Second,
elastic search. Same thing we are doing.
We are running a search through the
elastic search index. We have the index
name here which is reviews and we are
searching a query string. In the queries
the search term we are converting it to
lower case to cover as much breadth as
possible. And whatever characters that
come before and after it, we are taking
that and we are adding some default
fields to enhance the search. Again, we
are running it. We are executing the
result and returning whatever that data
comes with it. And as a response, we are
saying that we are returning the stream
of response as it becomes available. And
in our front end, we are just reading
that response as it comes through.
Right? There is nothing to see in the
front end side. Now, moving on. This is
a demo. So let's say I want to run a
query for the keyword laptop. Now laptop
and let's say I hit search. This is our
elastic search results, right? How much
time it took? It took around 1 second.
And our database search it took around 3
seconds. Almost 4 seconds, but 3
seconds. Now run something else. Let's
say let's say something only. and we hit
search and elastic search results is
already ready in 500 milliseconds and it
found around 8,000 results. And our
database also found the same number of
results because to keep it fair, we are
kind of keeping the search criteria the
same by converting it to lower case and
matching any characters that come before
and after. Because in this demo, we just
want to show the speed, right? Even if
we run it one more time again our
elastic search results is here in 500
milliseconds and our postcrist search
results is still running and it took
around 7.5 seconds for the database
results to come even though the number
of results same the time it takes is
significantly larger in a relational
database with the I like base syntax so
this is what I wanted to show where you
have a use case of any kind of search or
type ahead
things like that you go ahead with full
text search you can go with posgress
full case full text search or elastic
search a tools like elastic search right
there's something as a backend engineer
you should have in your arsenal you
don't have to master it or anything it
is knowing the knowledge of elastic
search is not as important as the
knowledge of database knowledge of
database is something you absolutely
have to master you have to master how to
work with databases how to optimize them
how to understand indexes is every
single part of it because that is
something that involves almost 99% of
your codebase as a backend engineer. But
elastic search is something that you can
get away with just by copy pasting some
snippets from any LLM or any docs. Now,
of course, if you want to optimize, you
have to read a little more into it. But
most of the use cases, most of the
examples provided in these docs and in
these snippets are pretty much more than
enough to cover most of the search based
use cases. That's pretty much all about
full text search, full text search, and
elastic